raspberry I feel like I haven't been
more wrong about anything in my life
[Music]
to me ice cream is like a very good
boyfriend there when I'm sad they
weren't happy there when I'm angry
you're happy you're sad like I screwed
up I actually didn't like ice cream for
most of my life as of recently I like
discovered ice cream it's almost like
dangerous for me now I feel like tasty
ice cream would be like all the flavor
names are probably so cute you just
imagine like s'mores ice cream
space-themed galaxy twist triple cookie
dough ice cream scream creamsicle dream
that's a good name honestly let's try
that I'm so ready
that's a fudge I like wow that is so
rich so there's like a client today
there's also like a saltiness this is
like here's a peanut let me ask the
crunch there's something else in here
[Music]
it's pretzel I think this might be
called triple chocolate tornado space
chocolate pretzel double fudge pretzel
crunch yeah that's that's pretty Oh
chocolate caramel pretzel growl oh wow
you got it
where's this peanut butter flavor coming
from yeah how did you know pretzel
you're like a pretzel connoisseur over
there like I feel like I haven't been
more wrong about anything in my life
you nailed it Oh back title next one oh
my gosh lots of colors that's strawberry
this is like blackberry cobbler just by
looking at it I feel like it's like
strawberry mango but I'm probably off
judging by what I did last time
blackberry crimson likelier pie there's
speckles of yellow and red which makes
me think that there is raspberry girl I
would bet money this is library
I feel like raspberry texture that it
genuinely does feel peckish
oh maybe it's cake it could be a
blackberry cheese
some are raspberry shortcake blackberry
cobbler blast it's white chocolate
raspberry lava cake Oh raspberry
raspberry you would imagine this flavor
a to be really sweet but it's actually
not like I can keep eating this and I
want to keep eating this like entire
thing I like it looks next okay before
I've invited it looks like there's
caramel in there wait is this like is
this created immediately
I can smell peanut butter marshmallow
wow you're really good I taste
marshmallows you don't know about our
chocolate peanut butter cup and
marshmallow you can taste so much in one
little thing and I'm like yeah it's
pretty good oh there's like a little
white chunk in there oh my god what do
you think this is called is this like
peanut butter s'mores peanut butter
campfire swirl Oh more smash you were
spot-on I was wishing for that s'mores
like ice cream and the universe hard me
and it gave it to me I think because I
don't eat them at sugar I'm getting a
little bit of like I should sugar high
right now I knew there was a spring oh
my god there's a sprinkle so colorful
unicorn party it's like a crayon truck
in a nice cool truck crashed into each
other there's like little star bits in
here in the star what are the star bits
of maple it tastes like a pancake
birthday cake a maple leaf I think this
one is either birthday party or unicorn
space swirl unicorn party +12 that Wow
no vanilla Gallic I knew it galaxy in
there yeah you did Elise our unicorn in
the title so it's much more like festive
galaxy this isn't like the mysterious
galaxy that nobody knows about you know
past the Milky Way
my favorite one is gonna be the
chocolate caramel pretzel crunch
chocolate caramel pretzel crunch
chocolate caramel this would get me
through sometimes peanut butter s'more
smash for someone who's like Heike
obsessed with peanut butter and this is
this is the one my favorite is the white
chocolate raspberry lava cake this is I
got the fact that I thought it was
blackberry
I'm tying these two because I love
salted caramel and I love peanut butter
overall these were really
they were really good y'all know how to
combine flavors that are unexpected I
like how well thought out there and make
them make sense
I would definitely sit out home with
this one and a glass of wine I'm gonna
take this oh yes
[Music]